WELCOME BACK.
BRITAIN'S QUEEN ELIZABETH, SET
TO EXPERIENCE MILD SYMPTOMS,
AFTER TESTING POSITIVE FOR
COVID-19.
BUCKINGHAM PALACE SAYS, THE
95-YEAR-OLD MONARCH CONTINUES
LIGHT DUTIES THIS WEEK.
ACCORDING TO UK MEDIA, SHE IS
FULLY VACCINATED.
BRITISH PRIME MINISTER, BORIS
JOHNSON, WISHING THE QUEEN A
SWIFT RECOVERY.
CNN'S ANNA STEWART, JOINING, US
FROM WINDSOR, AND IS COVERING
THE STORY.
SO, THE QUEEN IS DOING WELL, IT
SEEMS.
SHE WILL CONTINUE WORKING THIS
WEEK.
>> GOOD MORNING, LINDA.
IF EVER WE NEED PROOF OF THE
QUEEN STOICISM, I THINK BEING
95 YEARS OLD, HAVING COVID-19,
HAVING MILD SYMPTOMS, BUT
CONTINUING TO WORK, ALBEIT WITH
LIGHT DUTIES, DEFINITELY, IS
PROOF OF THAT.
WE ARE TOLD THAT THEY SOMETIMES
ARE COLD LIKE, IN THE PALACES,
SHE WILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
MEDICAL ATTENTION, WHICH IS AN
INTERESTING TURN OF PHRASE,
PERHAPS, FOR SOME QUESTION THAT
MIGHT INCLUDE HAVING AN ANTI
VIRAL TREATMENT, AND DRUGS,
PERHAPS.
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW, AND I
THINK THIS IS A RUNNING THEME
WE'VE HAD IN RECENT MONTHS.
THE PALACE DOES NOT GIVE US A
RUNNING COMMENTARY OF THE
QUEENS HEALTH.
IN RECENT MONTHS, OR HEALTH BIT
OF A TURN FOR THE WORSE.
SUGARBUSH IS A, WE WEREN'T SURE
EXACTLY, BUT WE WERE TOLD TO
GET LOTS OF REST, AND SHE
CANCELED A NUMBER OF
ENGAGEMENTS.
SHE ADMITTED LAST WEEK TO
FEELING FRAIL, IN A PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT.
SHE IS 96 AND A COUPLE OF
MONTHS TIME.
I THINK THE POWERS THAT BE ARE
DOING BEST TO KEEP OR
COMFORTABLE, AND NOT ALARM
ANYONE.
THAT IS A MESSAGE WE CAUGHT
YESTERDAY.
SHE HAS A MILD SYMPTOMS, AND
THEY WANT US TO KNOW THAT.
BUT, THEY HAVE SET, YOU WILL
CONTINUE WITH LIGHT DUTIES.
>> INCREDIBLE THAT IF SHE KEEPS
CARRYING THE WAY SHE DOES.
ARE ANY OTHER STAFF, OR ROYAL
FAMILY MEMBERS, IN ISOLATION,
IN THIS POINT IN TIME?
>> THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
QUEEN GETTING COVID, REALLY,
STARTING A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO,
WITH PRINCE CHARLES TESTING
POSITIVE.
IT IS BEEN A COUPLE WEEKS IT'S
THE, FULLY TESTED POSITIVE, A
FEW DAYS AFTER THAT, HIS WIFE,
THE DUCHESS OF CORNWALL,
TESTING POSITIVE AS WELL.
THEY KNOW PRINCE CHARLES IS OUT
OF ISOLATION, AT THIS STAGE.
IT IS A SMALL BUBBLE WITHIN
WINDSOR CASTLE, AND EVERY SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN.
IT IS CALLED THE HMS BUBBLE.
IT SEEMS TO BE THE CASE, IN
ADDITION TO THE ROYAL FAMILY
HAVING CASES IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS, THE ROYAL HOUSEHOLD DOES
AS WELL.
WE DON'T HAVE SPECIFICS, BUT WE
WERE TOLD AT WINDSOR CASTLE HAS
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE HOUSEHOLD
WITH COVID-19.
PROBABLY THERE IS, MORE ONE AT
THIS STAGE.
A HUGE CONCERN THAT SHE'S 95
YEARS OLD WITH COVID-19, IT IS
PROBABLY AN SURPRISING, GIVEN
THAT RESTRICTIONS HAVE BEEN
LIFTED IN THE UK, AND OMICRON
IS SO TRANSMISSIBLE.
>> EXACTLY.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU, AND GOOD TO
HAVE YOU HERE ON THE BRIGHT.
WELL, NOT YET IN WINDSOR.
>> NOT YET, JUST COLD AND
WINDY.
>> STAY WARM, GET A CUP OF TEA,
WE WILL CHAT SOON.
DESPITE THE QUEEN'S POSITIVE
CASE, ENGLAND IS MOVING FORWARD
WITH PLANS TO AND ALL ISOLATION,
QUESTION POSITIVE FOR THE
VIRUS.